aber schokolade ist ein
grundnahrungsmittel
hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren letzte woche haben wir bereits
auf dauer reagiert wie sie im schwimmbad
feststeckte
jetzt schlägt die da schon wieder du
bist echt der absolute wahnsinn
allerdings werden der dollar heute nicht
halbnackt im schwimmbad ziehen und auch
nicht fest gesteckt in einer rutsche
sondern dem gefängnis
ja wir werden allerdings nicht direkt
auf diese folge hier reagieren wo sich
dort im gefängnis befindet sondern wir
schauen uns erst mal an
wieso sie überhaupt ins gefängnis musste
ohne offizielle erlaubnis adobe einen
stand aufgebaut und versucht nun ihre
delikatessen den mann zu bringen
erinnern dumme hat er mal den traum
schokolade herzustellen hat super
geklappt sommer hat sich nun auf jeden
fall gedacht dass sie sich einen stand
selbst in die innenstadt stellt und das
darf man halt nicht ohne erlaubnis
[Applaus]
[Musik]
eine bifi mit schokolade dran ich frage
mich bei der mittlerweile doch kein
kunde ist in sicht die arme
die bürger von elfen kostüme angezogen
kann man sich wollen die offensive gehen
die leckereien verkäufer probieren sie
jetzt für nur zwei euro zwei euro ist
auch menschlich gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend mal probieren
das große plus 2 euro aber warten sie
mal ich hab da noch dass ich liebe diese
frauen haben absolut daran sind ich hab
übrigens auch wieder ein schild da
hinten geschrieben doppel im knast
lasten daumen hoch dafür da oder gar
nicht richtig getroffen
doch mal wollen sie mal probieren ordnen
sekunde keine events von der donner
fazit der ecke lacht aus das ist
ekelhaft das ist total epa probieren sie
doch mal
[Musik]
vielleicht haben wir einfach keinen bock
auf schokolade doppel versteht die welt
nicht mehr
sie findet ihre selbstgemachten
eigenkreationen einfach nie dieses
gewürzgurken dies gewürzgurken mit
schokolade wollen sie mal probieren
danke außerdem ist er schokolade hat
gewonnen transsexuelle kingsley machen
dann hat das männer zu sein ich frage
sei mittlerweile echt nichts mehr bei
dem was geht denn da aber ganz kurz
nochmals sich ein stand auch aufgemacht
und der innenstadt und belästigt leute
mit schokolade
ja da braucht man gar nicht mehr viel zu
sagen tom ist ehrgeiziges schokoladen
projekt wird zu einem totalen desaster
alter jetzt kommen die polizei
können sie uns erklären was sie hier
machen ich mach ein foto event alles
macht werbung für meine soko ihr seid
politik und werden so angerufen die so
hejl polizei wurde gerade beschlossen
von alter trick die frauen der
innenstadt mit schokolade was lasse ich
mich denn hier jede woche ein haben sie
denn die genehmigung für den kleinen
stand hier ist ja immerhin eine
sondernutzungsgenehmigung die haben also
entscheidend muss keine erlaubnis für
ihren stand hat dann müsste ich sie
bitten dass sie uns begleiten auf die
wache warum führt
ich werde nie wieder raus lassen
wahrscheinlich wird sie dann zumindest
mal abnehmen und da kommen noch immer
nicht ihre identität preisgeben will
wird sie der justizvollzugsanstalt leyen
ist sicherlich also damit wurde jetzt
festgenommen weil sie der polizei
gegenwärtig kooperativ war und sie hatte
keine stand lizenz für ihren schokoladen
bude da in der innenstadt
da allerdings das richtige gefängnis
voll ist die zellen ist sie jetzt in
einer justizvollzugsanstalt gekommen und
darauf reagieren wir jetzt als nächstes
sind so stark wie direct der top
kommentar ist like wenn luca konkreter
darauf reagieren soll ja mache ich ja
jetzt allerdings habe ich mir für diese
knast folge nun auch wieder einige bingo
kommentare rausgesucht von euch unter
meiner letzten doppel reaction was ist
das denn oder du trägst doch nicht
richtig das brennt ihr die letzten
gehirnzellen aus das ist das den moment
marianne an um was zu fressen
damit stellt oder setzt sich auf etwas
und es geht kaputt bzw zerbricht ja mal
schauen ob davon was drin vorkommt in
der heutigen folge
dommitzsch und knast hat tatsächlich
wieder hunger ja zehna wenn es so im
knast aussieht als wenn man da so
rumlaufen muss alter wie sich aus
wiesent dickes zebra wird uns das aber
nicht so thomas geschmack
[Musik]
schokolade welt ja ich mein showbiz
leben
und obwohl die wenigsten gibt es nicht
nur das wasser das sehen okay sonst
nichts schokolade ist doch ein
grundnahrungsmittel water frage ich will
das nicht aber ich bin kurz vorm
verhungern da bleibt mir ja wohl nichts
anderes übrig rafa suppe wenn wir dort
mit damit nimmst du wenigstens mal ein
bisschen was ab alltag nur wenige
minuten später nun ist die tante
marianne zu besuch bei der dame im
gefängnis und hat ihr etwas mitgebracht
du willst ein buch liest das buch
ich bitte sie alle gehören in die larven
jetzt als sie nicht gesagt das hat sie
dich gesagt wie es hier mittlerweile ist
es bei mir so dass ich zwar lache in dem
ersten moment wenn du mal einen satz von
sich gibt aber danach denke ich einfach
hey die meint dass wahrscheinlich sogar
er hat das weder tuchel ist es jetzt
gemacht dass auch verdammt noch mal
[Musik]
die schokolade das in einem buch andere
schmuggeln so waffen drogen irgendwas
madonna kriegt schokolade machen ja der
ist genial
ganz vorsichtig sein dass der wärter
nicht gut bekommen nein
[Musik]
das bringt mir wieder die ganzen die
hirnzellen oslo hallo hallo diese dumme
gierigen muss jetzt krieg ich vielleicht
noch eine anzeige weil ich als clubs mit
nachnamen das wusste ich gar nicht wie
wir bestimmt nicht lange am besten noch
mit dom in einer zelle die frist mich
doch auf ihre variable teil wieder ab
und verpasst ihm jetzt gerade für eine
aktion
sie kommen jetzt mal mit voller dahin
ist ja noch etwas in den mund und auf
mein mund aber ich will sehen dass ist
das was um alles in der welt ist gast
der in bockum regelt da schon wieder es
ist so ekelhaft
[Musik]
ich glaube es gibt da auch noch so eine
papierrolle roben also mittlerweile bin
ich ganz ehrlich ich weiß ich sage die
sehr häufig aber ich frage mich einfach
gar nicht mehr was da abgeht bei denen
das schade sowie die faxen dicke jetzt
kommen hier ein setzt sich entsetzt sich
darin sieht denn da hat nicht 'hier
anzuketten das bringt dann wenn der weg
ist dann weiß ich das einfach durch
egal was passiert hier heute ganz damen
überstunden machen haben heute
geburtstag
egal also wir werden schon sachen
eingeblendet weil die folge jetzt vorbei
ist ehrlich gesagt habe ich auch genug
gesehen in den text steht sogar mein
name drin
ok ja meine damen und herren der stelle
durch das heutige wie jetzt auch beenden
wir haben tatsächlich heute mal wieder
keinen bingo sieger 5 kommentare habe
ich mir ausgesucht und kein einziger
kamen darin vor meisten kommentare waren
allerdings natürlich auch sätze von
marianne und die ist ja schon nach einer
minute
rausgeflogen weil damit direkt die
schokolade gemacht hat allerdings hoffe
ich dass ich meine reaction hier dennoch
gefallen hat wenn es getan hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video da
schreibt mir auch jetzt wieder und in
die kommentare einige bingo setzen die
gesagt werden oder dinge die passieren
werden in der nächsten folge immer daher
schaltet auch nächstes wochenende wieder
ein wenn ich auf dumme reagieren werde
abonniert main kanal als noch kein
abonnent zeit und falls ihr schon
abonnent klick auf die glocke
denn dann bekommt die direkt
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video laden jetzt kommt das outro
[Musik]